[Music]
when you play the game of Thrones you
win
will you die
[Music]
there's only one war of the masses and
it is here hey everybody its charlie you
guys all probably saw HBO's release date
trailer for Game of Thrones there's a
couple Easter eggs in here I'll explain
what's going on they're pulling a Marvel
for everybody that watched the infinity
war trailer last year they're kind of
doing the same thing where they're
trying to mislead you a little bit so
I'll explain some of the Easter eggs but
george RR martin also did an interview
talking about winds of winter so we got
a whole bunch of new stuff to talk about
there's a new round of that fire and
blood book giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video i'll name a new
winner at the end of this first big
thing about the trailer if you guys
haven't noticed HBO the past couple of
weeks every week has done this big
marketing blitz so early theory they're
building up towards an actual trailer
reveal they're just trying to get
everybody hyped up heading into the
holidays they kind of did the same thing
last year with a couple marathons but it
wasn't quite as big as what they're
doing right now and that's because the
season as we know is premiering in April
much earlier that it was premiering last
year so they're not waiting quite as
long to start promoting it thankfully
meaning we get new Game of Thrones
material faster but I think most of us
were a little confused with the slogan
they were using to promote this trailer
for the throne because at this point in
the story most of the main characters
don't give a crap about the Iron Throne
really this is like Circe's slogan she's
the last person that's holding out like
I will not give up this power but start
to finish these are the clips that they
put in the trailer you have Jon Snow at
the Battle of the bastards Daenerys at
Illyrio's house in season 1 getting
ready to get married to Khal Drogo
Cersei about to do her walk of shame
then as the camera focuses on the red
keep the quote-unquote Iron Throne they
give her that voice over dialogue when
you play the game of Thrones you win or
you die then you start to see a pattern
emerge in the way that they cut these
clips together so you see characters
losing their lives attempting to win the
game of Thrones quote-unquote but the
problem with this is is that like Ned
Stark for instance like you see the clip
of him getting beheaded by Joffrey he
was not playing the game of Thrones like
he did not care at all he didn't even
want to go to King's Landing he only did
it because he was commanded by his
friend and his King Robert Baratheon so
you're starting to see that the trailer
was cut together in a very misleading
fashion
like most of these characters didn't
really care about the Iron Throne when
they were doing these things
Daenerys with her dragons burning Pyat
pree in the house of the undying Jamie
on the field of fire battle last season
then Jamie pushing bran out of the tower
window during season 1 Sansa
greeting the returned bran in Winterfell
last season tyrion being led to his
trial
Joffrey getting married to Margaery at
the purple wedding ned stark's betrayal
by Littlefinger in season 1 Littlefinger
being executed by Sansa and Arya last
season some of the clips do play into
the idea of when you play the game of
Thrones you win or you die Littlefinger
definitely was one of the characters
that played the game of Thrones they
highlight some of the major betrayals
the red wedding sir Jorah Jon Snow
confronting Theon for his sacking of
Winterfell back in season 2 the Queen of
thorns poisoning Joffrey during the
purple wedding they highlight some of
the major alliances the wildlings
joining forces with the Nights Watch
during hardhome Jon Snow's northern
alliance to fight the Bolton's the
Karstarks in the umbers weirdly enough
they highlight some of the risks people
took Jaime and Cersei --zz long-running
relationship that's another good example
of something that doesn't really fit
with the for the throne hashtag because
the reason for them being in that
relationship doesn't really have
anything to do with their play for the
Iron Throne it would be them splitting
apart like that would be a sacrifice
that they make for the throne and they
didn't do that Jaime only left at the
end in his leaving had nothing to do
with him wanting the Iron Throne they
highlight some of the sacrifices people
made most of you realized that Tommen
throwing himself out of the window here
isn't them showing you Tommen's
sacrifice for the throne it's Cersei
sacrificing Tommen in her pursuit of
power when they flashed the card of the
othes people swore in the night Kings
army marches south into Westeros they're
mostly referencing the Nights Watch O's
to protect the realms of men there's a
couple more clips of Jon Snow protecting
everyone as they race for Daenerys
dragons last season and then they
flashed the hashtag for the throne so
infinity war style they're giving you a
fake Hulk to mislead you about what the
true theme of season 8 is going to be
mostly I think because HBO doesn't want
to give anything away before they're
ready to like we'll get a trailer with
proper footage and it'll I'm sure be cut
in a very misleading way so we'll have
to try and figure out how they're trying
to misdirect us but just remember that
this is a really good exam
of how marketing campaigns almost have
nothing to do with what the actual plot
of the thing you're going to see is they
do it with movies all the time
Marvel is now famous for it Game of
Thrones Season eight is gonna be one of
the biggest things that HBO does in a
long time so they obviously want to
build as much hype as possible without
giving anything away until they drop
that actual trailer which hopefully will
come sometime in the next month so
remember there's a progression of
marketing campaigns first you get
pictures then a couple weeks after that
you usually get a teaser or a trailer or
something like that usually around this
time of the year every season they have
revealed some kind of teaser so no
worries the real purpose of this was to
get you hyped up and to reveal that
April would be the release date but if
you think about it this way True
detective is starting in January it'll
air all of its episodes and then there's
a rumor right now that big little lies
season 2 is gonna air after that HBO
typically only does their 1-hour dramas
once per week so that means that all the
true detective episodes then probably
all the big little lies season 2
episodes Sunday to Sunday then unless
they're gonna start doubling up episodes
on Sundays to get through big little
lies season 2 faster the earliest Game
of Thrones season 8 could premiere would
be the last week in April which would be
April 28th they have not released the
official schedule for big little lies
season 2 so if we do find that they're
gonna double up on episodes to get them
out quicker and premiere Game of Thrones
faster I will totally do a video about
it but right now it would just mark your
calendar tentatively for April 28th like
I said though there was a big winds of
winter interview that George art Martin
did he was actually trying to promote a
couple of his other series and he has
the fire and blood book coming up but
every time he does a big interview he
always talks a little bit about winds of
winter so this is actually pretty good
he talks about how the show has made it
harder for him to write the book so this
is me reading his quote verbatim he says
the show has achieved such popularity
around the world the books have been so
popular and so well received that every
time I sit down I'm very conscious that
I have to do something great in trying
to do something great is a considerable
weight to bear on the other hand once I
really get rolling I get into that world
and that happened recently with fire and
blood I was going to sleep thinking of
Aegon and Jo Harris and waking up think
them and I couldn't wait to get to the
typewriter the rest of the world
vanishes and I don't care what I'm
having for dinner or what movies are on
or what my email says or who's mad at me
this week because winter winter isn't
out all that is gone and I'm just living
in the world I'm writing about so that's
him just saying that the show has become
so big that expectations for winds of
winter and dream of spring have gotten
so big around the world that is causing
him problems when he's actually sitting
down to write but recently there was an
illustrator doing the cover for one of
the international editions of winds of
winter that said they finished their
cover so they expect it to be released
sometime next year the publishing house
probably wouldn't commission a whole
bunch of art for the book if they didn't
think the book was actually gonna start
selling within the next year but the
other really cool quote that he had
about winds of winter as he said that
I've been struggling with it for a few
years the winds of winter isn't so much
a novel as a dozen novels each with a
different protagonist each having a
different cast of supporting players and
antagonists and allies and lovers around
them in all of these weaving together in
an extremely complex fashion so it's
very challenging the idea that winds of
winter has grown almost too complex for
him to finish in a timely fashion has
been a thing for a long time in the
fandom like everybody realized that a
long time ago if I do get any more news
about winds of winter are there any more
rumors I will totally include it in a
video no breweries and I will do fire
and blood videos when that book is
released congratulations Ryan Watts
you're the giveaway winner from my last
big video please email me on the about
page of my channel so I can get your
contact details click here for my Game
of Thrones season 8 episode 1 preview
video and click here for my history
video on the ancient stark kings of
winter thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight